Je ne te comprends pas Devereaux je suis celui que
tu veux vouloir prendre ton coup tentant
mm-hmm donner ma position même si
j'attendais de mourir pour la cause d'un maçon
voici l'ennemi tu m'as appris ça ouais
je n'ai pas  J'ai fini d'enseigner mon fils,
mais ici, je suis sur le point de t'abattre tout de
même tu ne vas pas m'abattre
gamin tu es au mieux un instrument contondant aucune
perspective aucune connaissance continue de parler
mec c'est humiliant
embarrassant comme à Moscou oh  mec qu'est-ce que c'est
Mason personne pour te tenir la main
personne pour te dire d'appuyer sur la
gâchette toujours dans la voiture où il y a un
parking juste devant par ici
donc pas de regrets pas un il est là il est
par ici quelque part drastique en arrière
toi